Film Courage: Brooks, we're going to give
you 14 idea fragments.
You don't have to use everything.
You don't have to use all of them.
You can throw any of them away except one
and we want to see how far you can get into
the process while taking us through your process
the best you can and for those of you watching
if you want to play along at home, great please
do the same and we welcome you to pause the
video and see what you can come up with and
compare your ideas to a professional writer.
Okay are we ready?
Brooks Elms, Screenwriter/Filmmaker: I’m
ready!
Film Courage: Okay, screenwriters on your
marks.
So here we go, 14 idea fragments.
Single mom.
Brooks: Single mom.
Film Courage: $500,000.
Brooks: 500k
Film Courage: A train.
Brooks: A train.
Film Courage: Memory loss.
Brooks: Memory loss…what I forget.
Film Courage: A small town in Michigan.
Brooks: Small town in Michigan okay.
Film Courage: The power of silence.
Brooks: Power of silence.
Film Courage: A yellow bag.
Brooks: Yellow bag.
Film Courage: A man with a checkered coat.
Brooks: Man with a checkered coat.
Film Courage: Two friends who haven't seen
each other in 20 years.
Brooks: Two friends who haven't seen each
other 20 years.
Film Courage: An abandoned castle.
Brooks: An abandoned castle…butchered that
spelling of abandoned.
That's fine.
Okay.
Film Courage: A life-threatening dare.
Brooks: A life threatening dare.
Film Courage: A mismatched pair of detectives.
Brooks: A mismatched pair of detectives.
Film Courage: Rebirth.
Brooks: Rebirth.
Film Courage: And lastly this piece of dialogue
“They don't realize how powerful I am.”
Brooks: They don't realize how powerful I
am.
Cool…okay great.
So the first thing I’m thinking about is
what spoke to me like when I go down these
prompts it's like what is it where where do
I feel like I might have a personal take on
something right single mommy mom was single
so that I feel something 500k is a significant
amount of money maybe I mean it's sort of
you know heists and crass and sort of material
and maybe train is a great location certainly
a big history in cinema history of trains
or strangers on a train or lots of different
I actually wrote up the first screenplay that
I wrote was a passenger that I that I sold
was commuters on the l train in Chicago getting
trapped in the blizzard during an alien invasion
so but I can't do that already wrote that
one so that's that memory loss is certainly
interesting but not so much to me I'm going
to put that one aside small town Michigan
okay maybe certainly I spent some time in
the midwest so that's possible but probably
more toward the end of the list doesn't I'm
more called to the train and then you later
have a location with the the castle an abandoned
castle which is kind of interesting I visited
England once and went to see a castle and
it was it's interesting it's what's nice about
that it's an elevated location it's sort of
just could be a warehouse right but it's you
know has this history and it has all these
metaphorical powers to it so maybe there's
something there power of silence that's interesting
one of the things that makes cinema powerful
is you can just watch what people are doing
and you can it can it can hit you on a deep
level Scorsese said once someplace that I
really appreciated he he would sometimes watch
his own films if they came on tv or whatever
and he turned the sound off and just kind
of watches his shot selection which is a really
good way to focus on your subtext what are
the characters doing what do they want also
it's a great way to make sure the scene construction
is is muscular and powerful if you had the
sound off could you see what the conflict
was and what are they doing so yeah so there's
something there certainly lends itself well
a yellow bag I mean that was going to be used
to pull over somebody's head to kill them
okay otherwise i'll feel connected to that
man with a check or coat that sounds like
something potentially could be in some sort
of detective piece or whatever I'm not that
called about that two friends who haven't
seen each other in 20 years I am all over
thati deep relationships with people I went
to high school with and child latu and I that's
probably pretty common but there was the I
in NYU my senior thesis film was about me
was based on when I took my girlfriend home
to my hometown and I had really close relationships
with my guy friends and I kind of got myself
in the situation to be choosing between my
girlfriend and my guy friend ended up winning
a screenwriting award there so that's to me
that's the most loaded and interesting idea
of everything so far right and who knows maybe
this is two single moms who haven't seen each
other in a long time maybe they're on a train
and maybe they're going to rob the train for
500 000 terrible idea but anyway that's just
that's not where I'm going but single moms
I haven't seen each other in 20 years I mean
I'm not a single mom so I wouldn't go too
far into that as my protagonist probably I
can I write women they're half the people
on half the characters in all my screenplays
so I can like these days me being a white
straight male writing a single mom driven
movie is you know there's resistance thereand
it's it's other people's story souh the son
of a single mom my bad that I get that's personal
to mebut these two friends haven't seen each
other 20 years they meet on a train is definitely
something that is speaking to me see single
mom maybei want you maybe one of them is traveling
with their single mom that feels personal
to meand maybe they're going to see this abandoned
castle in london right or outside of london
so now what I'm doing is I'm taking these
elements and I'm connecting to things that
have happened in my life that I could bring
out authenticity with I could make them something
that it's like what's my personal way in when
I write with this one writing partneryou know
his superpower is sort of creativity and inventiveness
and he loves sci-fi and fantasy my superpower
is grounded characters person they're grounded
personal characters and I write tension that's
really thick generally in dramas or thrillers
so when I write with him it's like where's
the double filter where do we bothlike when
we both speak to so um
and so sometimes when we're looking at fragments
it's sort of you know when he and I are maybe
brainstorming new concepts or when I brainstorm
myself I kind of take fragment ideas and I
kind of start and if he and I guess what reason
I brought up is if he and I are disagreeing
about something he like kind of likes something
I go yeah but I don't have any personal connection
to it and then we go okay fine I'm going to
the next one or vice versa so that's what
I'm looking for here when I'm seeing these
fragment ideas it's like well what's my what's
my personal connection to it if I'm in a general
meeting with a producer or something like
I got this book and we're thinking about bringing
in a writer to adapt it or whatever I go great
let me hear it and I'm looking for some sort
of connection because
i can make it sing when I'm writing about
this dude I went to high school with who fascinates
me you know that that's really what I'm writing
about and I'm just sort of doing it in this
certain way that kind of connects sookay a
life-threatening dareprobably not a dare doesn't
interest mei'm putting that at the bottom
of the listnext in yellow bag which I won't
use a mismatched pair of detectives well that's
sort of if I was working with like a producer
who was like I want to do a movie and it's
got to have a mismatched parent all right
I might you know it's part of the you know
like maybe these two friends they meet on
the train they haven't seen her in 20 years
and something terrible happens on the train
maybe it stops in the middle of the woods
or something andthey have to be a mismatched
pair of detectives to figure out what they
all happenedyou know I'm just kind of I'm
there's two things I'm doing I'm trying to
say what what is it that I can bring something
to from my perspective on lifeand then how
do these elements sort of piece that together
but the key is not to force it right a mismatched
pair you know that element general mismatch
para detective feels a little you know a little
forced to me but it can be really fascinating
because detectives are interesting if you're
doing any sort of mystery story and mismatch
is always good because you know we all have
poles inside of us part of us that's this
and part of us that's that and you know any
sort of buddy love story what blake snyder
would call has these two different characters
learning from each other so maybe you know
these detectives are puzzle pieces that need
to learn how to fit together so that's possible
that's possible rebirth I mean that's kind
of a theme sure you know we all have rebirths
times but I wouldn't really force a theme
that much at this point I don't think man
with sugar coat we're back to and then they
don't realize how powerful I am.
I mean there's definitely some juice there
you could do something with that line in a
certain way it's kind of a heartbreaking way
to take it if you if the character really
doesn't believe it the character is in this
place of going I'm not enough I'm not good
enough whatever and says they don't realize
how powerful I am but doesn't mean it at all
you know the subtext of that is really beautiful
and heartbreaking and that would maybe yeah
anyway so yeah I mean that's so you know that's
that's a little bit 10 minutes so this is
how I would approach it so I'm kind of I basically
reorganize the list and put the ones that
were like the ones that I had some sort of
connection to more towards the top and towards
the bottom and for the hypothetical if I was
going to go for further I would just you know
if for some you know I mean that's not how
it works I mean working the businesses they'll
say i've got this story and maybe it has some
of these elements I mean it might there might
be some sort of novel that has those sort
of elements but this is sort of missing the
narrative drive or something so which tends
to be more the core part of a story which
is why if somebody would option a book or
something but like does that answer your question
in terms of how I would think about these
things in terms of putting them into a story
like if you were to take some of these pieces
whether you use just one what if you just
all you did was was build it around the two
friends who hadn't seen each other in 20 years
okay you just said okay I'm gonna take that
and you know that that resonates with you
because you have close relationships with
people from your hometown yeah and so okay
you can go somewhere else so you want me to
come up with a concept based on one of these
pieces sure and if one if one and if you say
you know what actually this yellow bag what
if one of them finds $500,000 in a yellow
bag and now they have a moral dilemma do I
turn it in what do I do yeah yeah interesting
well I’ll pitch an idea that these two friends
are on the train and they haven't seen each
other in20 years and maybe they had a history
of some some bad things back in high school
that they did maybe not too bad but like some
trouble and one guy's desperate and he's got
an opportunity to steal $500,000 from x right
so and he hasn't seen this guy in 20 years
and he knows at least back the way he was
before that like this guy is the perfect guy
it's almost like strangers in a train which
is the premise there with the Hitchcock story
was I’ll do your murder you do my murder
and that way we have no alibi and we're both
we're both more likely to get away with it
so maybe I would pitch this as a spin on that
but it's not Hitchcock was great but he also
had a very kind of you know bulk boxy sort
of stiff you know performances and kind of
you know it was just older different different
time but if it was like a yeah a modern story
two friends that haven't seen each other and
this one guys already has this heist in mind
and desperately needs his 500 and runs into
this friend and is like oh my god this guy's
the perfect guy to do it and then what's what's
the blocking agent why is um
is it the guy you know like maybe even like
one guy's a dirty cop right so one guy's a
dirty cop and and the guy that sees him is
now a criminal and maybe he's trying to recruit
one guy's trying to recruit the other for
some sort of heist or something he's guys
are best friends in high school andso what
I'm doing is I'm sort of pitting sort of deeper
personal elements in a way that could feel
kind of personal not that i've ever robbed
anything or anything like that but like loyalties
among friends and taking some sort of risk
for a heist experience is pretty compelling
I like heist stories I like I like crime stories
so yeah so I could see that as sort of a I
mean it's kind of a low low you know there's
high concept there's low concept but you know
it's it's okay it's it's interesting so if
you were to so if let's say that's the story
so let's sayI ’ll write a long line out
of it when when two friends two they were
not what kind of friends they were outsiders
they were two kind of down and out friends
one's a cop we were called down and out friends
one cop and one crook who haven't seen each
other in 20 years meet on a train they decide
to team up to steal $500,000 right so that's
functional but like so that's like and that's
actually where a lot of sort of beginning
writers might stop right okay they do it and
then the but the problem is if you don't go
any further with that concept it's just flat
it's sort of like I mean you have to that
dialogue would have to be phenomenal and crackling
and amazing so what really makes this better
as a concept is who are these friends is one's
a cop what type of cop is he how how dirty
is he and then and if it's like this thing
where the the crook needs to the cop for one
thing and the cop needs a crook for one thing
and then there's these loyalties that are
at play and who knows maybe you know maybe
they stopped being friends because one guy
hooked up with his girlfriend back in high
school and then that comes up at a climatic
part where one guy never really effing forgave
him for it you know I could write a story
like that I mean again it doesn't feel I mean
I'm looking at it for 17 minutes now but like
but this is a process I would go into it and
I would say what and and I and if I was I
would first of all I wouldn't put a ticking
ten clock at night I would kind of play with
it for a little bit and then I would sit down
and set it down i'd go someplace else and
then was in the shower or whatever might come
to me and go okay what if what if this happened
with this guy and then what if that happened
and I would play with it and I would get it
to a point whereyou know I felt like okay
this is something that's kind of interesting
and then I would pass it around to my feedback
circle say what do you guys think is this
you know I might have them rate it from one
to ten I might just pitch it to them and then
look at the response and if again I you know
step one would be me getting to a place like
that I feel like I'm really excited to me
right now what I put together is rudimentary
it's like level six out of ten as a sort of
concepts right it's much easier if you start
a new script and it's like a level nine concept
with a level 10 concept right which is unlikely
for you know most people to do when they're
sitting it's looking at something for 15 minutes
but that's the things we you know we don't
have to do this we have as much time as we
want soi would just keep going back to the
well and playing with it go what about this
or what about that and then you know if I
ever felt a little forced and just put it
away and then just do something else and then
once I got it up to a point where I felt like
oh this is actually really great and and also
the other thing that i'd be looking for that's
really good that I got from Blake Snyder is
irony so where can you add some irony to the
story so two down and out friends one's a
cop one's a crook they haven't seen each other
in 20 years they meet on a train one guy realizes
that he's super desperate and he's got a shot
at stealing $500,000 bucks and his friend
from high school is the perfect accomplice
but yeah they you know one guy slept with
this they stopped talking 20 years ago because
one guy slept with his girlfriend and they
got to deal with that or maybe that's got
to be dealt with up front and then he goes
okay we'll do it and that breaks into sec
into your second act and then as we go deeper
you know why did he sleep with the girlfriend
what did they really love about each other
that was betrayed back then you know what
do they really need as people and then the
movie really becomes about you know I don't
know if it comes about a rebirth but it comes
about them sort of because I had deep friendships
in high school I mean these guys I love these
guys because partly because my father wasn't
around as much as I want him to be so I have
abandonment stuff so one way that I dealt
with that abandonment stuff was having really
tight friendships so my friends and I did
not sleep with each other's girlfriends but
there's betrayals of different sorts or whatever
but I would sort of tap into that thing and
it would probably have to do with some if
I was gonna write this or develop it and I
had to use those elements I would start playing
around this idea of abandonment and how I
dealt with abandonment and how these guys
have dealt with abandonment and what do they
do about it and yeah so that's kind of that's
that's what I got I mean that's sort of my
process and you know looking at it for 20
minutes you know how I would approach it why
would I i would approach it that way and at
the level that I got to this what I will say
is a this is like I said I don't know 60 70
it feels like it's it's there if it's what
would make this from just being an exercise
to something like oh this is amazing I want
to really write this at some point probably
another element or two maybe there's a sense
of irony that I could bring into it or maybe
a way to elevate it maybe it doesn't take
place sort of modern day but maybe it takes
place on the moon or the international space
station or something or it takes place in
like the 1860s and I'm in a place where I
really want to you know explore that sort
of thing but what I'm looking for is that
personal connection to it something that I
feel like yeah I'm on the planet to do this
you know and then another thing I would do
early on is going okay well what is it like
okay it's sort of like strangers on the train
but like you know I admire stuff about that
but that doesn't really speak to me now Pat
Garrett and Billy The Kid the Peck and Paw
film from 72 or 73 that blows me away and
that's about friendship and betrayal so maybe
I do that maybe I go in and go okay two friends
who haven't seen each other and maybe it's
sort of like with Pacquiao and Billy The Kid
they were outlaws together and then they were
pitted against each other so maybe I would
do that I would kind of milk what I love from
that comparable and I would go okay how would
peck and paul do this how would this happen
so and again the key is not forcing it so
I would never put a 20 20 minute or whatever
never put a time limit I would I would just
get in there and play around and that get
to the point where if it was fun to keep playing
I would and if it stopped being fun i'd just
do something else maybe with a different story
maybe whatever and if I was in a meeting with
a producer and they were pitching this idea
it would still be the same thing it's like
you know I either can bring something to what
this you know the guy's vision is for what
he wants to do whether it's an original or
an adaptation or something or I can't and
I'm not attached to either outcome you know
because it's that's the thing is because it's
it exists beyond me it's like I'm not even
it's not me the more I think it's like me
my screenplay blah blah blah it's like that
just gets in the way what I'm doing is trying
to be in service to the audience that would
want to see this let's say it's a crime thriller
or a heist film andand if I am the man to
serve them with these sort of ideas that just
came to me and they're in service great you
know and you want to pay me a lot of money
for that awesome and I'm not I'm not attached
to anything but you were able to find things
that you emotionally plugged into even if
it was just 60 70 percent there like the man
with the checkered coat you were like yeah
yeah whatever abandoned castle yeah i've been
to one it was kind of cool it was eerie but
it wasn't something that you really felt like
maybe a deep connection with but the two friends
that hadn't seen each other that really and
why is because my personal life my psychology
my psyche was formed around this abandonment
issue my dad took you know my parents split
when I was in third grade my dad died when
I was 17.
So I dealt with abandonment as a core issue
my whole life and so I have world-class insights
about how to deal with abandonment in good
ways and in bad ways and everything in between
so you know you got abandonment issues you
come to me and I’ll you know we'll have
a good conversation and my stories when they
come from that place now you know what I mean
now it's like it makes some sense right and
I can touch on other things but like that's
that was a core one for me so that's why those
friendships meant so much to me and I mean
it was like and I would not only I had a group
of friends in high school but I had like best
friends and we were like this you know really
you know a couple different ones but like
and it was probably because I was hurting
so much because I miss my fathers that for
a screenwriter to have that sort of insight
into whatever however your psychology works
and however your triggers work can then fuel
the choices that you make so they're loaded
up so that you're not just writing oh I'm
doing an action film it's like yeah that's
that but it's actually a metaphor for this
time in my life where it drove me crazy and
broke my heart and because the movies that
we love and shows that we love are melting
our hearts because the people creating them
are basically sharing their memoirs with us
they're sharing their diaries and most intimate
vulnerable places in their life with archetypes
or personified in these characters that are
iconic in a way so that I look at Goodfellas
and I feel like that's my me and my friends
and we never did anything with a mob I grew
up in New York but like way different side
of Long Island and there was blue color there
were similarities but again like nothing like
those guys and yet exactly like those guys
and that's because Scorsese and Pelegi were
so specific with the people that they grew
up with and they allowed that to manifest
in a movie like goodfellas and with such delight
and specificity that yeah it feels like it's
my story.
For The Viewers: Share your logline below
along with how much time you spent on it.